my name is kojo Paris I'm the chairman
of a free Africa we were a social
enterprise and we're particularly
excited by the fact that the fifa world
cup is coming to south africa and of
course South Africa as the host nation
will probably disproportionately benefit
but it's impossible for South Africa to
benefit them from something this large
without there being corollary effects
across Africa and Africa itself we
believe is going to have a very positive
stage on which to demonstrate all its
potentialities so South Africa will be
the main beneficiary but certainly going
forward Africa will be highlighted and
we'll have the opportunity to show it
swells